last week this is true California
governor Gavin Newsom signed a bill that
allows California residents to eat
roadkill yes a new California law allows
drivers to eat roadkill it wasn't late
at least we weren't supposed to before
it was unclear Andy but no governor
Newsom has made it clear that now we may
eat roadkill and now some people find
the idea gross but others are leaning
into it in fact get this there's
actually a chef who specializes in
preparing roadkill I had to find out
more I thought we'd bring him on the
show tonight to show off some of his
dishes please welcome chef James Arnaud
: hi everybody
okay chef Arno this is a fascinating
what are you making today all right well
I got braised chicken with Apple
stuffing I got roast turkey I got pork
ribs two ways and I just started a
hearted beef stew mmm worth the wait
believe me okay
I'm confused chef none of that is
roadkill
oh it's roadkill all right chef no I'm
sorry
everyone knows roadkill has things like
dear squirrel possum that sounds nasty
but that's your idea of roadkill you're
not driving down the right roads yeah
please elaborate okay what you want to
do is drive on roads near farms where
the farmers are careless careless with
their gates you know the pigs wander off
the cattle break through the fence is
where the free-range chickens our little
- free-range it's all in my new book
where the good roadkill roads are that's
right okay yeah there's a lot of Pro
tips in there like how to smear chicken
feed on your bumpers how to pork cattle
feed on the highway turn off your
headlights and just wait okay wait a
minute wait a minute
Jaffar no I mean this all sounds
criminal yeah criminally delicious and
by the way if you don't eat meat you can
always buy my other book how to hit a
guy coming out of Whole Foods with a bag
of
let's look at chef James R now everybody